you're a feminist yes
you know I find myself I don't know
maybe I'm going crazy in my old age but
I'm I find myself agreeing with the
radical feminists more and more than I
do with the leftists or I'm sorry more
and more than I do with the Liberals
okay elaborate on that for me well there
was a great clip that was going around
of Catherine McKinnon are you familiar
with her no I don't think so Catherine
McKinnon wonderful great radical
feminist
and it was her debating some
conservative over porn
and uh she made this point she said you
know you conservatives some of you
conservatives are tolerant of porn you
think porn is no big deal and obviously
since the Internet it's exploded
everywhere and it's caused a lot of
problems uh and she says but you know
imagine if you were in your apartment
and you heard some guy knocking a woman
around oh every single wall abusing some
woman and and what would you do I hope
you'd go over to the apartment try to
stop it I hope you'd call the cops but
that's what you're doing when you're
when you're watching porn and this weak
conservative he said well you know but
people will have a right to look at
whatever smut they want and she said
what are you talking about you know
that's completely insane and the the
conservative said to her well well don't
you agree with that all these free
principles of just watching whatever you
want she said no because I'm not a
liberal I'm a feminist I'm not a liberal
I thought I guess maybe I'm a feminist
too who knew yeah
I mean are you would you describe
yourself as uh she called herself sex
negative
you know that's the kind of anti-porn
feminists are you the anti-porn feminist
or the pro-born feminist yeah because
largely are the pornographic industry is
a huge issue as far as perpetuating and
supporting sex trafficking and human
trafficking and so no yeah I'm not a
supporter of the porn industry as a
whole now as far as like I think we'd
agree on something yeah and as far as
like sexual Liberation and the ability
to you know consciously and responsibly
consume porn I'm not necessarily opposed
to that but the large porn industry as a
whole as it supports uh sex trafficking
and is largely unregulated I am yeah is
it only the trafficking that bothers you
or is it
the women who are involved in porn
come from bad backgrounds almost all the
time and usually neglectful and abusive
backgrounds and they're very vulnerable
and they're completely exploited and
they're paid pennies and they're treated
literally like meat and then they're
thrown out two years later and it's just
the whole thing's so ghastly right and
it's not uh that's not a matter of
trafficking exactly but it's still an
exploitation yeah but then you then you
just said that you don't mind people
watching porn in certain circumstances
right if if the industry was better
regulated people were paid living wages
there wasn't this whole situation where
people feel you know pressured or forced
into that industry based off of certain
life experiences or certain certain
circumstances 100 of the time right well
not not necessarily 100 I do feel like
people can consensually and responsibly
um you know participate I mean that's
not necessarily what happens like I see
and I think that that is sort of
dehumanizing and I think right but
that's also removing the consent aspect
because there are a lot of people who do
do sex work responsibly and they do so
of their own volition so you
so before you were sounding sex negative
like the radical feminists now you're
sounding sex positive like the Liberals
well I am sex positive but oh I mean it
depends all right never mind I thought
we agreed on one thing finally okay I
mean we agree that we both do not like
the porn industry as a whole but you
wouldn't would you ban it
the porn industry yeah
frankly according to the law it already
sort of is largely banned it's just a
few Court decisions kind of screwed that
up but yeah I mean I think that things
like only fans should stay legal when
they are run I think that if it is run
by the worker themselves and it is there
deciding to do something of their own
volition then I'm not necessarily
opposed to that but I do think that the
porn industry should be banned or
regulated as a you know as a whole well
that's good so people should not be
permitted to look at PornHub for
instance that's what you're saying yeah
I think PornHub should be shut down
because a lot of it is you know
unregulated and kind of there's a lot of
things on there too that perpetuate
abuse that perpetuate um you know
radicalist ideas of you know
objectifying women
um and so that yeah I definitely not so
does that not undercut a little bit of
your argument about bodily autonomy and
doing what you want you know in your own
bedroom with the blinds closed I mean if
a guy wants to go into his bedroom and
pull up some disgusting pornography and
uh do whatever with his own body you
know sex with someone you love as Woody
Allen described it uh is that not a
matter of his personal bodily autonomy
that he allegedly has a right to I
believe he has the right to do that but
like I said it doesn't happen oh you do
it doesn't have to be done through
PornHub there are responsible and worker
run but what if he really likes PornHub
what if that's his that's his favorite
one well we don't have to protect his
right to access PornHub no I don't think
we should no that's good all right
that's something but only fans who think
is okay yeah I think only fans is okay
because like I said it is run by the
workers themselves and they aren't
exploited by an industry and they aren't
forced into certain things don't you
think that
pornography intrinsically is
exploitative and degrading I guess
that's my problem with it there are
other problems too I mean it's not just
the consent is what I'm saying because
you seem to think that the only moral
Criterion that matters is consent if you
consent to do it then it's fine and
dandy but I think there are plenty of
things that you can consent to do that
are not good
and are degrading and feed your basest
passions and enslave you and should be
illegal and are illegal even today in
some cases
yeah elaborate on that well like drugs
would be an example right I don't think
you have a right to do drugs but I don't
think you have a right to do all sorts
of things you know I don't think people
should have a right to cheat on their
wives maybe a married man can sense to
sleep with his secretary or something
and the secretary can sense it I think
that should be illegal and it was
illegal for a lot of American History I
don't think you would have a right to
that I don't think that if you uh are
under the delusion if you're a man and
you're under the delusion that you're a
woman that you have a right to chop your
Healthy genitals off any more than you
that you would have a right to walk into
a doctor's office and say Doc I identify
as a quadriplegic and the doc says man
you've got problems you know you need to
go see a psychologist you know I'm not
going to chop your limbs off but then
that same man walks into a doctor's
office he says doc I'm a woman that doc
says wow oh my gosh that's so brave and
wonderful you're a stunning beautiful
woman let's get you onto the operating
table and cut off the Family Jewels that
seems to me Preposterous I don't think
anyone has a right to that I guess
ultimately I'm saying I don't think you
have a right
to wrong
well what we Define as wrong is
different between you and I because I do
agree in providing gender affirming care
to people because when you are in a body
that doesn't feel right to you and you
do not identify as the gender that
people perceive you as that can have
psychological consequences and again
when we look at Medical experts who
study this and provide this care they
agree that gender affirming care is
essential in order to prioritize the
needs of these patients what about Dr
Paul McHugh I don't know so Dr Paul
McHugh was a doctor at uh Johns Hopkins
and was the pioneer of the gender
transition surgery and was the head of
their gender clinic and so he pioneered
the whole thing then he found after a
few years that it wasn't improving
psychological outcomes he didn't find
that it was damaging psychological
outcomes in most cases but it just
wasn't really doing anything and it
wasn't helping and so if it wasn't
helping he shut it down and so he's not
only one figure in
the transgender Care Medical Community
whatever I mean he's he's a preeminent
figure in it and he says that it's awful
and we should stop the surgeries so does
his expert opinion color your views at
all no so in medicine we are taught
something called paternalism is
something that we should avoid and
paternalism is essentially putting your
own personal views into the health care
of other people so if you believe that a
patient is going to regret this decision
then you are going to you know prohibit
their access to this and as medical
practitioners as Physicians like we are
taught to avoid paternalism and acting
paternalistically is unethical so but
that's an interesting use of the word
paternalism so
by that you mean just having opinions
and acting on them no no it is a
specific terminology in medical ethics
it is not prohibiting your patients
access to Medical Care based on you can
give advice right but I don't think you
should drop your genitals off or I don't
think you should have an abortion see
and that is putting your that is putting
your personal opinion that is unrelated
to medical studies and unrelated to
proper psychology why would you hold a
personal opinion that is completely out
of step with reality would you I mean I
just fail to understand this distinction
between a personal opinion and say a
public opinion a professional
professional opinion yeah I just don't
see if if
if they disagree the professional
opinion that you're supposed to hold and
your personal opinion and if they're
contradictory only one of them can be
true so if if the professional opinion
is true then why do you hold your
mistaken personal opinion and if your
personal opinion is true then why would
you give a damn what some lunatic who's
telling you to perform a lobotomy has to
say